here's the dirty secret that no [ __ ]  that's gonna talk to you over the next  weekend is gonna tell you you want to go  from a million to one hundred million  it's about people there's no algorithm  there's no platform  there's no [ __ ] math arbitrage to  build something from a million to a  hundred million you will have to tap  into your EQ skills not your IQ skills  and you'll have to realize if you're  even capable of it because if you're not  you're gonna have to bring in a partner  or if somebody you trust for life to  build out that because you have to scale  humans and to scale humans you have to  know how to deal with humans and that's  the truth